Salut, aujourd'hui je vous donne une énigme !
Oh quel surprise !
Bah non, c'est pas une surprise puisque durant 32 jours,
je vous donne une énigme tous les jours, c'est notre petit jeu à nous de l'été.
Et avant de vous donner l'énigme, je vous donne la solution de la vidéo d'hier.
Si vous l'avez pas vu, commencer par regarder la vidéo d'hier,
puisque là je vais donner la solution.
La solution c'est que le fils a 3 ans et le père 33 ans.
C'est comme ça qui cumule pour faire 36.
Spontanément, vous avez forcément pensé à 30 ans et 6 ans,
ce qui ne fonctionnait pas, par rapport à ce que je disais dans l'énigme.
Non, c'est 33 et 3 !
Il fallait voir le calcul d'une manière un peu différente pour le trouver.
Je pense que vous avez été très nombreux à le trouver.
Je regarderais le quota de pouce en l'air pour voir le nombre de bonnes réponses.
Et cette énigme m'en a fais penser à une autre, que je vous donne aujourd'hui.
Énigme 26, l'énigme d'hier, la 25, elle m'a fais penser à celle-ci.
Qui est hyper intéressante en fait !
Quel nombre dans tout l'univers des mathématiques,
mais c'est pas des mathématiques complexe, des mathématiques normal.
Quel est le nombre, qui quand on le divise par lui même donne comme résultat son double ?
Ça parait impossible comme ça...
En même temps sinon ça serait pas une énigme,
mais c'est tout à fait réalisable.
Je vous laisse réfléchir à ça.
Si vous trouvez la réponse, mettez un pouce en l'air,
qu'on voit le nombre de bonnes réponses par rapport au nombre de vues.
Mais ne mettez pas la réponse dans les commentaires, pour laisser les autres chercher !
Profitez encore du soleil et profitez-en aussi pour vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir !
Car le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an !
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h.
Ciao !